HOST:E W ANE JREOIBYD HO AUTI.ES
RGA
GRETRRT HOF,AF W NAS H A
EW
UTOKBO O CWALEALD E:RGTEAT
W
ORHIST
MWEEDTIENONE EF BORUYOE  CAM
N
IS ITHE NNTH50 ARYERIVSA
THOFEA YR GAAT WER.TE
WHYOW N N ATO HEWIS
FRYOR
RGWATEE?AT
GUT:ESTOHE T SRYHA WE G LVEON
RE FERMBEDMRO WTEERATGA
,PA
OWEDSS DUGTHN ROH R THE
ET
ORREDFD MACIEOV,  TALTULYNSUR
T TOOTALE  BRET WLYHA
HA.ENPPED
MY GTHL OAWIHI TSOO BWAK S TO
CO
HE ATH OADF
50E TH
VEANNIOFARRSY REHE T BTH IAKN
S
TRARYE, TO PLET TOGRHELL A
T TOFHEWENGHIS AV HE LRNED
L TERHET AS50EA YRS ABO
EAATWH RPPY LLHAN EDEN IATTH
ORST
WATEISATRGE HIOM SETT  TNGHASHA
BEEND LI SCEINHO A TWAANUSD
YY
ORLL A S OF THOR N BS,UT
O
E ONTS HASEN  DOWTE WTORI
T ARTOIN FHISAR N
TIRAVE
ORHIST TLIY KE AS HIIN
TEQUARURCER-NT
SIENE NCTHAVWE,  HNELEE AR
L
S SORT NOFEW FHATSAC T
ART E
PET INRTENAND ANCHED GETH WAY
WTHATBELIE THYSTE OR
ACNFLYAL U
DEOLD.
ETHEV RNATELIOIDTHF E
TY
OFEE DPT,HR TOABIND A F DTOECR
--UTEPYIRECRTO, ETHEL RSEEA
N TOFHEAPONIX TE , ESTHELEREAS
POFERAPSRO ADUNNN CHEHELTAU
, FAAFIRI'ICWHH'MUR SILWEE  W
L
ATALKVEUTBO OCOTHR E FSEUR O
TH CONIORSVEAT
E ONOFEYHE T KGETR, IGNGRI
TSEVENE F  OTHL ANSCDAED ANON
THNT UILEC RTLENY MOPT OSPE
E
NODID  WKNT OWKE LASINTOD
ATTEWARGATE  A.LL
ETHLA DECATIFSSICNIO OLAL
IVRRNAATMEDOE CUS.NT
NK TWEHIF OGAAT WERTH ATES
ISN
EEN MOMS  TT,HIRGLA ATHE T
DEMOATICNAAT NIOITCOL MMETE
S FIOFCEE JINUNF O97 1 BUT
YENOU DTOE IVINHET, I W
U
Y FULLTADEUNRS TNDHE HISRY,
WHGAAT WERNS TTEUROUT O T BE
A M, DSINETANARI CMIL ASIBUVE
POR MDSINETT  THATERMPEEASHE T
WHXONIN USE ITHOE,NNIS H I
D
ROUTEIR CFESCL O B AFCHUN O
STARE NGCH WTEACRSUL PHOOPEAT
ITE THWHE HURSEOU DSG INHI
E
LEAND AD TWHO ATDOS  IA NZE
RRINTE BATELEDTI DUTISTNC
DASCANLS W THELILCERO PDU
DOSTINAONINTH, E DOSCVEO .TINAON
AT O EHENDWATEATE,9 6
PELEOPIL W BHAL VEDIN EEIN
,
UDINCLGINEWHE T NYAOR YK
ES
R,OWNEUR F AIGET  MOS DOPPELE
ALT NORES E IZWAATSOASCIH WEDIT
THL ANSCDA. AATLL
HO:' LETM'S E  SKEURWE
PEN
OULIONPHE SNE T FHEO ARMRO
S EWVIERON TW S HINEROOKBO F
MGA
GRETRRT  WF AFONTEERATGA
.(2
8-) 02740180E , THORNELI F
RES.ICBLAN
(28-) 02740080 D FORTSOCEMRA
7402(2) 808-02 FOREP INDSDEENNT
AN.HEOTRS
T LEME O ASKEC DURIR BR TOTONGRI
VEE THCORE F  OTHOK OTHE
SCIN AENGA
SATWH IT  THA THERONT
AE
HAOF TTK? BOO
WHDID U PUN ITT  OVEE THCO
U
T:ESHI TSS THCENTEPIEREC
OFND SHECA.AL
ITHISOFONS E ECHE T R
DIOG
ESCHMAINHEHA TT SLPREAP CTU A
OFVE CHEONNSATRSIOTOHA TT
RE ACINHAICRD'IX NO'S
VAL
OFINCEFI, AM CP DINIDAV,
AT
HEOF TENES RIDS , CEHIONLETEPH
E
NELI H HS,ISYEAIDWAE FF OIC
INH
OLD EC OCEOFF FIINUI BLD
N
ITD  IRETHS E ONLAVETIF O
OSTHE IAP TESN S THEMEUMRF O
7319ARA , YENTO EALCA SND
,H
AT CNGHAESHE T
TRACTOROFY
TIE THENRECA SALND.
AN FTHD ATEAALIN YHEOFR  T
SCANLDAM FROALAS BICY JLYUL
UGTHROHON NIX''ES RONNAIGTI I
SH
LEBAE TTHOOR F T TAP, TO
WHARLEN TS PATAREF  OTH CMERI
DANMI CRILINATY A ANDOFSEBUS
POWEREREAP CTUD O
ETHN OS
RE.INRDGS
HO:ST M HOWMEH UCTIOUID D Y
SPLID STTOINENG HE T TRESAP O
REE G INTHRIANTRSC?PT
ESGUT: TES TAPCOAV HE
T
OVEREAHE T Y.RS
B HITASE N EETHTBJSUEC OA
RUGINEAT BTLET BENWE
ORHISTO N IAWH FLPHEEDHECEOR T
FIOFSET T AP TES OUTEN  ITH
LA0' 1TE99A'S DN  THEREMOO S- -
MOE OL VUMOMVEHA C
UT O.
CCO TWSU VSIESVE OUMOLES
THE
WEPETAS LI PREUBEDSH ILATHN E
LEEA YRSHU, A EF BGEEN
O
HINSORSTIASEEC BAUHE TAP TESRE A
MESS
S IT ITEWOHY TE T HATH
N
LIARBRYND AATIOL AR
IVS
NHAVEUTEREV PUT OUDIN FIT
E
RIANTRSC TS PTOFWNIRHE O
.
HTHEYEAVEFT IS T
NSORSTIATEO  TINRERPTAU BECSE
S TAE PEEAR SH UCANUD AIO
S MES
ATHEYAT RREELPRELIVY EITIMIV
RERDINGHN TECOGOLYOMSO,  SOFE
ICE THVO AREARD TO
EA .
THRDREE COGINEV DESICE  WERTSE
THE  SCRSEET DVIERCELLRIED HESOL
HEOMFR TM OT BTOOFHE T
IDPREST'E'SES DHESOK  T
OPMICRATNEHO SBEUS JT EW LOTH
HIANYTT  TNGHAS PPHAEN
TOE
BLE SLINDOUS EX AKEN N.OSPLIO
SOSEONMEE N  DTSOWEECOA FFUP C
ANND SITOU ALIS KERAAR C C.SH
N NIXOTOKELIS ISUT P H F
TN
THE TLEABN WNDHE H TDOE ESTHA
ND SITOU ALIS KEGOOM BB F.G INOF
PEE THTASARRE A HDENLIO STO T
DAN HANTOISRISE  HAVNNEDO A
IBCRINEDEF BLEENOU TITO
UNCOYTRDE TO  TPHCIERVESEHE O
R
ARE THYE
HO:STDERE PSION NNTIXIC BASLYAL
EDPAEXNDN O WEST HAPR
ENIDT
DIWHY D PNTSIREDE WIX NON
AN
HIEREVYTOR RNGEC TD DEINL OHEVA
OF?CE
EST:S  THIGIBENSACO  TTEH Y
INMESOTHT ABG OUYCE THPS
LY
ICOF RIXRDHA N.ON
SHE IFAHI TS ININSCATGRA CHAERCT
A
EAOTNN RD Y LLANMESOTHAY WS
HIONN  W E TCHHEIRNTE HGEINF O
AMD A ICANTHE TH20RYEN CTU
RNTUS.
YO AHAU VEFRUR TN  N TOMHE
EW
REALDE GIE SATOCTYICOL PIT
T
EDPRECEDIM HO  TE E THAG
OFRE
HAANAG TOWFOT LLED. HIM
ARRICHD SIX NONMSS EEHIFELA AS
TRATFOS RMEIVDERE PSINT
AD
ASWAS OO P AALUR FKAIG
E.
WHEAS OTHN EEPUBCAN''
ALTINAONT IC TKEVEFIIM T
IN
COTHE F SEUR OTHE TH20 CEN
,
COA RERD TLYD IEONY B. FDR
HEN AS W OMETIINAG MAZ'E'ER COV
55MOESIM, N  TREHAFUA LL
R
IMOF TZIMAE GASOV CERTU FEADRE
D CHRIAROVXONIN  C TERHEOFRSOUE
HI.RECAER
CHENTESOM IOFF OEIC.
RSE THFIG THT IN DOEIS TREA
T OUCOE THREINRDG STEYSM
HAT
ONLYND J HNSOHONPL IADN E.AC
ANHE WHI NTSOTDO TNGO ITIT WH
ISAS HDERE PSIGIY NCBE
TNSO
UNFO,T  WHAIVFEEFCTPPY ELHASEN
T  TISHAHERS FEA T IT HAHE
T
G GOIN GTOETT RE CDISR FOHI
GREVACT HIENEMTSND AAIHA TT
I
RY KKEERIS K ANGSIERNG GREOI
-TOYHE- NRSI KISREERNG A
G
AL STOTEHELL A TT RE CDISR FOHI
GBIIS DEC
NSIO.
HES EG BINL  FTOEEIS AHE
SSEES LEOOMNERRE IKKE
INKISSRGE S T OAYNENGHIEN  ITH
OVE FF OICEND ANTHERHI WSP
SOINTHGLS EHEATE  TOCKTL
RTPAS IEINETEO GRGN
.
NRHEYIS K INGSIERSAWHE T H
KND A
DESIHE TVAL FICE
OCVEDO CPAAIKTL  SIERTS,O NONIX
TSGERU FDRASTTE.
LS FHEEETHIK LE TRE UEISTO
IS H PNCSIREDEOTISY  N
EG
URCAPT.ED
ASHE HECHE T SRVT RESEEIC
L STINALECISTH SCOT RERE
ING
KSTSYEMO WNNO TLLRTVIUANOY
E
DEINSIIS HWN OISDM AINN,ATTRIO
SO THEUR FIGE CESOM
HROTHUGVAIS H OCEOFL FI
OM E
UGTHROHIH SWAID HEAYRNE, VE
UNINTARSND ATHG EYNG BREEI
EDCORERD
.
S IT ITNO UNEILNT OE F  OTHALOV
FIOFCE AID
--HT EIG- - AESID
TSAYSSTS HISYST EEMXIST THA
EVOWNEYO NSTND UERDST THA
ALCOESTHE TIERNVSAEYS ONTH
HAITAD H WN NIH XOEEVEHA B
N
PTCAEDUR
TH B TENHEBETLATE BONSGI A
UT
ETHEETHR OSAP TESUL SHOBED
EDTURNTOVE OR TINV IES.TOGARS
HO:ST WOMWEE LCELLR OUCA
D
CO.ENMMTS
) (202018-7480OR FRAEM DOC.BCA
LALER OTH2) (S,200048 7-8
TOYOU HUC O YWHN ATOUAI SD ABO
ENESPRIDN.NIT XO
YOTE WROTSAT,  I ST,PLIMES
WAISATRGE HE T SRY O
TWO
RASEPATERI CCONAMIL CIPINSRA,ES
XOE THNID'WON RLSIR DCK TTYRI
SE
ATO ED L TRGE THBURYLA A
EQSUBSNTUE CP.EROV-U
THCORSFIT CYPINSRAAS W
BEDELITERA TTBVSUER T2 1HE97
ELON.
NDSEE COAS WEA RANIVCTE
S EMTOPE HAPLESIN MISEEC BAUSE
NONE O S.D AINO
DCHRIAR NONIX NIDOTR UF SFEY
L LEGAUENSCOEQROESNC F
MWA
E.RGTEAT
HEDO PASAR GD NEBYALERD
OD
RAFTE H ICAE MEFIO NTOF.CE
ATWHOU CLDE  HAVPPHAEN
TEDO
ARRICHN NID XOY?GALELL
GUT:ES AT  IISRE GATIOUE QST
NAN
THOND E MS LATOO A O LOTRVE
DER OUMOCO DRNIS
SEUR.
RTPAATF  OWH TAK MESSHI SORYTO S
REO NTVA TUSYE 50 SAR IAT LER
E T WAY HT HAWEEAVCH WAT
E
DASCANOF T TRU
ADRANIMISTONTIOL UNFDR  OVEETH
IVSTLA FS.YEE AR
IND ANTHT ABK OUETH CENSEONQUSCE
STO TE OMOFSE HH-LELVE
ALFIOFCI
OMIN S, WAE YSTIE THENREEAT BTL
E ATTH WVEHAEE SN BWEENONAL
R
D P UMANDEE JOBI TOVN ER
HELA
PL CSTOUS WEE EKDAN MTHS
OVTIXE ECUVERI P TLEVIGE
S
CTDIRELY B WK ACTOTEERATGA
.
W WITASTEERATGA
HA TT
BLESTAFOHEISD FITHR E MET RSTI
THDE IA AIF CNDODED IETH
ISEXOFNCTEE TIXE ECUVE PGEVIRILE
INST FHEIRLA PCE
SEN XOASXEEDRT ETIVENI
ILPRIVERE EGOV THO TSEHAESAP T
E
BEAV HE ENSSIS DCUG.IN
ASATTH WDUR TNESI ATH BDEY
ESU
COEMPRE T.UR
S TAPEELREWE RSED.
THALSOE -COKD LESMSTG INPI
OL
ERCONVTIONELPSO TEA LTOD
DCHRIAR'IX NO'SNAES RIGNONTI I
AUGU 1EA4 97AHDF  OERATWH W
EX
TCTPEEDWOBEO  TLERT AICOF
PEIMTHMACENT  THAUSE THHO
WS
G GOINTORI BA TNGO E  VOTDAN
ASENTH PSN  O S TTOHEFOATENE
RR
L.IA
REXONIN  AGNSIEDF ADHE O
LF
ATTHHEND A TLDGEN RA FDOR
SRDPAON HT  JIMUSWEFEA W SEK
TELARCABA, SIKIY LLMA
TNGE
ATLCCAULATN IOTHVE ENHO THUG
UFORDANERNDSTMI IDST STT GHCO
HIM TCT EHELE 1N IOIN697 T
E
OTIS N TOI GNGBLBEO  ATOE
GORN AIDPRS ESTEN
F TH
EFO
ERRMSI PR'NTDE'SEG L
ABLOUESTI CREONTOINNUG ALTR
UN.LD
LLE THFU SF PECO ODCHRIAR
N'NIX'SS RI CMES D ANHIDAN
NIMIONRASTTI'' -RI CME
MIADTISTNIRA'O'SRI COKS METO
O
E TNGIMS OR F URN LTOEA
F RTPA OETH MGYHOYTLOIHA TT
TA TN  OINSHIISOO BK
WA HGTINONRN LEAS TEDHI
XIMAM, ETHER COV AP -UIS
AYS
WOANE RSTHHE TME CRIH WH, IC
IO
AN MYE EO PPLETHSO LESOFN
ATTEWARG
RIF NHAICRDADONIX HT  JUSME
EACLN AUN HG A C
PLOUE
CIOFFITS ALOUY,O  TDR HAY MBE
CYIDESEN HOU WLDRVE AVSU
.
UTE THTRICISH  RRDHA 'ONIX'S
ESCRIMER WE B.AD
E THERANREWE MOFY  TM.HE
UTHEYDOLNFDECR AWIS OSA
NGRAE OFRI OUTTGH CTYNAMILIDE
ESD ANPRALENIDTI AOFSEBUS
IWEPOR,NGLUNCDI OBU ASELCIF VI
RTLIBESIERIND A PFCYVA O
AMITANIC C
ENIZS.
STHO: W IAYUCO  TTOORONH  M
GOT OUG ONRD LDYID H AND AOWEAB
NMATHIK LE  I GATOTD OLNVVE
IN
NITHE N CAAIGNBU, TVEE  WHA
CAINWAS ITFOG ROU Y
BUT  FIR TSTOAMIL WLISTN  IWE
VI
IAIN.
CAERLL: A H IADST QUENIO WHIT
THE TH50ERNN AIVERRYSA HT WE,HA
LEIRRENCVAYF  OXOE THNI
NAD
RANIMISTON CPAREDTH TO
TOINNDM AATISINTRNIO ANGSPS YIEL
ONITTI U.S.RE PDESINT AND
H
DI CENANANTEDAS THHOD W
ATWO
CTD ULFAORN IND AHE T
RIMISILAFESTI O ITUSND A JAT
T MMCOENOUOMFR YATN  OTH
ESGUT: T SISS  ARYTO TST HAHA
BEDINF UOLS  TNGHIEESTLA W
IS IADEHA TT
N  JOH, RHDUAMOWH,
ES IISNVNGGATITIARHE T E
LY
AGES OTRTHF E SSP UMRU
IGVEINSTIOATN H PASUTHIUT O T
HAEAID TE THT ERSWA SRTE OMSOF O
SPS FOEFRTT AIAGNSUME THTR
PWH
USE ITHO
S ATTH IATT NOWHOH JNHA DURMHE T
SPLIARO PR CUSETOIDS HASA
.
THOTAS H GN TWTEDP, U
IFAMPLDIE INHT RIGING DIA
INYECRRTL AFL CNDON
EDATA
H BUNCOFS HI TNGNFD ANCOATELAD
BUOFH EL TIM
ESIN.
YWHENAN UOUNTEGL W IT,T IT
LALTULYIKKSOO LE ISHA T
S
SWAER-  -THEAS S AT OROF
LOND SERTAGIN EORFFTGUR DIN
THAMOBADM AATISINTRN,IO
TO
Y STUDNSSRUIA MWAALRE
AND
IARUSSS FON CUETTEINRNICRA TFF
THAS WDINF UOL INGN WTOHIASNG
R
HENDOU THI WTE HN SEOU IETH
IVECEXUTCEOFE FIEF  OTH
IDPRESCYEN, ISICWHH T  SOR AOF
GRMFOALENEROVNMLTATRUCRE
N
H WHICESE THPR UENIDCYD.OLNFDE
HO:STO  DU THK SISHE NCWAGIN
-- WATGATEHA TICAMT ERSAN
METPRTYPEH UCEXND SCTCA?AL
IN WTH OERTHDSOR, EYEC EXP
TSC
PODAANL  BLIEIUN ANGRO
E
CONDERRN ANMOV GERT.EN
GUT:ESBS AY.UTOLEL
THS I IHE WRE WMAN NYES AYTH
LE OCYF WTEERATGAHAAS H CEDNG
SHWA, GTINONISICWHH YOHE WN
ULO
OKT A HRN JOWOUNOISALM
TRTSEAAR LTI IGENSS,TITUONW
S
NTMOMEE F  OTHMETVINAOFAR W,
THONNTPEAGS,AP PERF O
ATTEWARGINE HE '97 10'SEA RYLL
S RAHELDGECHA ANE N  ITHYWAHA TT
AMVIICERA S S EWITMEVEGORN
VIENRRT S EWASDERE PSID, NTANTCU
RICOVEER GNGOV T PSSENNMT.
YOTOADU D HI TSTIRA TDIONF O
S RISCBEFOBERE NNDONIX AHE T
IGVEINSTIVATERN JOUISALT W
TATED LEWAUSATRGE RED
EWISTH N SF LETY OORCHMU M
E
ESAGGRMUVESI, CHE MOR
ONESQUTIVEG ININIVIGSTAT
EREE SN
G RTPOINATTHVEE  WHA
NSAGAITHT E PNCSIREDEYLLND A A
MAERF  OGOHEOTR NTRNVEME
INNSUTITIO
INWAAN MY  C, YSIT TATREES
HEMI
RNOTUTR SUCTH OREF DOFRE EE
MF
MANF IORONTI ACTND ACYRI PVA
LA AWSNDIGVE ORSTH OHTF
EIN
ENLLTEIGCEGE AIESHO W
SEA N
F ESUS OWEWEPOR GH CREAUT
WATHE E RGTEATASORSTY
EL .
OMUCH WWHF ATNOE W KNOW A
UH
S  GATOEINONWRG  GENEROVNMT W
A
E TRN ACCKBA TOHE TAC LEGOFY
D CHRIARANXONIN WATEATE.
ST: TOMS  IRI FINLO,DA
ICPUREBLE. LANIN
ERCALL: IORAS W BANN DD AI RSE
N
,D.C.OR BN19 IN .72
ST QMYUEN IOISCE CONG.INRNG
GODY LONID
I ED TLISTHI TENO ORAS DI
SHEA YRSNDGO A AE HOULD
PUTHORRPT N JATOHHAEA DN
DSO
G THMEINWI DTOO THHE T
BRINK-EC BSEAUWA HE NGTRS YI
TOE RIETEVMAGINF IONMAORTI
YITRNGT O  TGENGMADAGI
INN ATRMION JONOH DN'E'S
.
IS AHE TRENY TO THRU TRATTH O
CAABU YOELONATORE  TT?HA
GUS  THIIS P OT AROF
OF
GRTHE TEATE MYSES OTHE
TEWASTATRGE Y.OR
RFO T ALLEN AHETTHAONTI TWET
VEHA PAITO WTEERATGAALFO, R
VEE THINIOIGSTATT TNSHA UDOLNFDE
, ALR LHE TPA9  6SEETTERA S
SF
IC IND TENTMTSMET HAI DIONTNE
OU TOFHERY STONENO,  OAS H
EEEREV BNRO PD CUSETEORHA CEDRG
I
ER OTHRDEG INTHAK BREN.-I
THEER A ARE OWI SRLF D
RT
RITHEO AESNDTO SESRI TTHA
AE
N GROWR  OUPVESTE THLA0 5
S
T ABOUAT T BURWEARGLS
REAC
ALTULYOI DNGE NS IIDETH
ATMODECRIO NICATMML NACO
TEE
CEOFFISTH ON INMOE RN O
JE
17,97 1
OSOME HTHF ATDO TASO H WIT
THANPLS ATNF UBEDEOLD REFOHEN
.
MOST ARICANO DNSO IZRET AL
LABUE RGT TRYHAHT NIGHEAS W TETH
SEND BUROFARGLY GAAT WERTE.
RSRGBULAEEAD H B CINN  A
PLE
SWEEK ELIARER W ANDMIE ERCO
NGE
BACKTR TO IXTOY  FAST  ALE
HEOF TEMRO PBLTHS ATNF UDEOLDN I
IRATTH FGL BSTURY.AR
SO IHE TRE OTHS ISLICFFIAOR THEY
T ATTH ISWA TIRS HITHRATE
, LARGRYISICWHH HA WTIX N'O'S
PRETSES CRCAY ARBEEE USTH
EVEW ATS F LAY DSERAT ANDHEN
THISE  S AF RLWI O
HEOTR
IESTORSBOUTD -  -ANESEOTHRI
ABROTT HEEO PO E PLWHVEY MAHA
HASO REARDTON  O B TERHEYGLURAR
IS- -UR BARGLS T ANDGHT HANI
TH
NTPOE TELIAOL REYB, MAEN EVE
THTEA CIAT TTIMPNGTASAO BO
GH
EARUR BGLANY DHA TE THT EREAR
LOT  STIY  VLLERENOP
TIQUESSONUT ABOTRHA WT EDSPANIR
COULBED  TATE RUTHHE TRECSET ARE
IPMULTNG TLEHILDUNS FO
G IT
CEONNT MEA IHE TREONRES ASO T
EVBELITHATHEREMUER WE
E
VEMOTIG AMS ONETHARUR BGLS
OWUNKNACTON  ER.OTH HE
HO:IT SO OULDBEAV HE
.
ONGORD AID LDYAR HNDOW
HUDT
FWERECIELREAN?NG
YOEWRU ITUT ABOCOHI TS
LEE
OFSET , LA PNSNDL ALKITHOFS  O
C
ESVITITI
HTHEYIDE AVSAISHI TS OFAR PT
TH.
EYTH TIR HEDGL BHEURS.AR
ESGUT:S THIESEC BOM -ICAM- ER
RYRGBULAENS  IWHARE  WLEDNEF OAA
THY DIE RT TICTRKSATT HATHAS W
EGETH B ONIINNGTHE ENTS,UT B
E TR TH UTOFTE MHEATHIISR  T
A
SY EA RLLKELI ARICAALKI
N
S TTOHEORONECD HI TRDFCT A O
A AYITH WL KNONOHAGEED TITT
END HABEOI GNG OMOFON R HSNT
R.RLEAIE
WH YATOUAW SRIIT WH ARCHDIX N
N
ORG.D  GNDOID LDYOSS  ITH
YRT THACKRIS  UBED ENNGOLNFDIDI
FOHAREMO TAN  YFOR EABEREHE T
LABURGT TRYHAIG NHT S ANDTORF O
TYITRNGRSUNO DELLNDTA A
THE
ERDIFFTIT ENMOLLS,VE AHE T
IASTHIORNS FF  HORALURCEA NTU
YO
:ST' LETH'S M  FARROGHHI
NINPOT,ARTHOR C
INOLA.
GOHEAD
:LLCAERHA T F YNKOUIN TORAKG M
CA
HAVEOVEE BN ERASHE T L
FEW
S YEARINGOGTRAC BK O NGYI TNDFI
OUT OUABT WTEERATGAND ANGOO LKI
ATF OT L OETHTI TESNDNYMO A
THGSE.NL OIN
WHAS IAT WY EA RLLNENCCOER
OUABTHWAT S THWAE Y TH MATAR
HEMITC T WLLAS BATREED
JOYN
HEMITCLL
HAE DRSIN MDEASND A WEDRU DGG
YDOL  DOUEANYTHWI AATF  OTHN I.
URYO
OO BK?
ESGUT: TCOS HIBEBIS MEA
PT
HEOF TOO BEASK  WK  LOONCKBA O
ITSYE0 AR WAT LERCLH ITA REA
ET SEOFS.YE
RTMAHAIT MELCHLINTH, E LYEDCRIB
KETSOUPOWIANN D LYLD FOUS
IF WE
HEOF TRNATN TOER GEYENN JALOH
LLTCMIHECATH, E  CAIMPGNEFHIOR F
XONIN I, 19N 68ECENTH BESOM
EYTOATRNEN GTHALER, ENEA LSVE
EYTOATRNALEN GERCOO  TBE
E
AICAMPGNHI CEF97OR F 1CE F2,OR
U
R AFT TEETHGL BURY.AR
E THONLARETIF IPSH ONDHNJO A
MACH MHAITLELESEC BOM O
F
THEEM SHRALIN TF DSEA OETH
ATTEWARGDASCE AN
MRTMAHAL CHITEL MS WAINYAN WS
FITHE MOT RSFASE CUSONEATRVIV
PUINENNGT CAME ARIORHIN ST
-- PDIANT-DI PUNTERN  IAMANIC.
ORHIST
ISTHY IL WDLKETSOUPONAN WOM
H
BIA HAALOFT  CNGP U RRSOREPTE
LAT AIG NHTND ANGIS DHI
T
WHATAS GN NGOI O TSIINDE
HE
XODINH  NASON N--IX
ADNIST.TIRAON
S E SHWASTE THMODE IN NDMA
R EASPKE C TINHE FNTOURY
REANBLPUICR OTS HEICANTH RRDHA
HIXONIN ELF.
SE SHWA TS KE
EIG FUR IN RT
USBECAE I SHEEPA S DEGI TLYRA
C
FIGU.RE
COE SHBESME DEDREEPSS
A HAE S M OBPRLETHWILC AH
.
SHEEISE  DYPL IAPNHPY
HENR
ILIFENGAS WHI JN TOASNOH
MI'HETCL'S S
USPOE.
EITHR RNSATELIORAP HIUNLSVE
AMDRLYICATALE N  ITHAFEKWES R
TEWAATRGERTN  IPASEEC BAU
ON
MI THETCLLO ESRI THEDEHI T TTHRU
T  WOFHADHANEAP HPE MFRD OMTHA
LLTCMIHESEEC BAUE HEA FRS T
SWIE LLAKPE TTHO E P
SSR.
ASLE CHEALIOMER NTHED,NE SAS W
LYTUACAL DRUEDGA AERSTIN H
WIN I CNIIFALORAEW A F DSAY
TEAFR TGL BHEURY.AR
DSE SHEN NP  UINK  YEWOR
ATE
ANDID HG.IN
D E SHANHNJOCH MITVEL ELNE
RSP
KEA AINGA A U ENDND
TIPASERANG U ANDELIMLTAT
Y
VODI
INRCG.
SH SDIE ESTEN OOAFARRIR CH
D
XONI'N'IG RES.TINAON
STHO'ET L'ARS HEGLRO FM
NN
FOCALI
IARN.
ERCALL NOARE E G UST INROU
SMMCOON
SEEN.
WEE  HAV CVEA RY
RUORPT
VERNNT F T AORLLSEHEEA Y
RN
ARHID LLTOCLY INEDPLN AY
RTPAE N  ITHATTEWARGEHI T.NG A
WEEDAT WCHDUS  AA CT ELYLE
ESPR DENIDT,ALONDRU TS, MPWAED
GEBOSATADHOIS H WLEDERE PSIYNC,
THPEH UGIMTHMACEN AND
REE  WWE
NOEI BNGEP REDSERENTRY  BOU
COTITINSTUEPALON R
LIUBC.
EEWE KAMSCP RERG INOUEM D.RAOCCY
IITE THS EST RRCOUPOPLE
T
BHAVE PN EEINORCELA F0 5EA YRS
TAURNGKI OREEDS AW,AYOT N
ENPRREESHENGTI TE,EO PPL
RENGENESTIMS THEVES ROUG
E FBIUGTH, ROMUTHH E
LEER
RERT AOU TNDHRPA CGH-S
WED HO SUL DVEHA ALIECIRT N.
O
ARE REPIVNTSEATD E WEDHO SUL
BERE REPIVNTSEATES  A
FRA E
TRCOUN
T:GUES OTH ONEF EOS MINAMT AZ
GA
S OFHE WTEERATGA ITO SRY
ALRETHINIZG EOL RLLOFE  A
E
S AYPLERE O WHARILL TH U
STO
Y.DA
E THLLCAER MEDTIENONRIL HLE
DHRO, ACALLYNG Y AOU
TOATEYRN, PA OF ETH
IGVEINSTINATGEA TM FOROUHE T H
ENACPEHMTTTOM CMIEELO A
E
JOHNOE D.RR
ISTH I OSOS RTOMINF  SEAY W
SWH
EERHE SHEET GS T STR AR
IN
TIPOLI.CS
S E SHWAYREALAD DBIINATG
INCLDN TOAN HERIAD H TBE TEDO
RETED TO THEMI COMEETT
.
AIHE ' ID,'M GOG TOCKO  GBAO T
KAARASNS T TNDRYOORUN R F
GORNOROUUT B YD HO SULYREHI M
GI.IEFRND
DSE SHENINP  UBE OPAG RT
TS
MMCO
TEITE.
ROTANHEEIG FURM  FRO-DDEMORN
TILICSND EUP AIG P
TF
WATHE E RGTEATTRRTDIY KSIC
IOEROPAT
HEAS TRAL CLE MENONTIEDYO, U SEE
THETUNS ITI TONTIS, A FHEBI
IN CA,OMING TOLA PY I
THS
Y.STOR
S ATTH I TE ONOFS  WHEAYATTH
ISTH BLPK OOHESEW RTERI
THE
PLACINE AT W BGAERTE NAUECSEDKOO
ONE UILNTHI T HBOS OKED TASRIO T
T PUINXTON CTEITHA WT EA MNS
DTHATPEEOA THRT WASHE T
FBI
DETYPUIR D
TOECR.
ITHATNGA S SILEACTHA T
YCADILLTEEW RRI
OUS RRA
TADEUNRSINNDGF  OASATWH WGAK TIN
PLINE HI WASTONGNAU BECT WSEHA
WEEE SE S  ITHATY WATHAR MK
'FEL'S LERKSEA WD AIE ME
TT
ARRICHN NID XOTBU ANGTRT YIO T
INTHK TG CT AINIFBEC DIRRTO
ISD ANTHTHDE IA P DATEEOA THR
TA
S TTIS HIANIX-NONID INSER
NGTRYIGHO  TFIGOFOT R
GONTRNVEMELLCT AUANOOE DS
BE ULDP WHUSCAE  WATESEE S ITHO
TH MARKEL FT IG DOS INME
-SSELFVIERNG BRAEAURUCC KNE
NGGHFITIO T T TRYOET GHE T
TB JOATHEBI FLFIM HSEHIND A T
S
COBESMENE OF O THEEY K
INORSTYLT  TESHA O AWEREWY NLNO
UNDEINTARSNDGH  WIT SFUA LLEPWE
TO HOFIS.RY
:HOST MGIN T19O 73 A
TNE
RGWATEMME ATCOTEE ARIN,GS
OUATWH YASIE VW HE TTEON LG-
W--ST HAWAHE TT FF EECSE TOFHOM
HEINGS
E THERNGLO-TCTEFM FEN HOTHAT
INHEART  TG,HATEMMCOITEDSHE AP
THE UT FURSSNGCORE
NAIOL
STINVENSATIGIO
T  I AIS QRE GATN STUEIODAN
ATE ONTHPES  ISUVARER LE
TO
C-NDANSP ATS IONIS MSIURND A O
VI OEWF TK  WHEORONATTH C
ES
ESDOECAU SAMIN ERV''
E ITMMTE IASTOM CET TESOGRHE
HEEROV TE OU CRS S TOFHEINPRG
F
1973WATH, E E RGTEAT
LESECT
COEITMMTES  INGEPSTPINT IATO
MEE THTITOER TRI.RY
ERTHISE T LM AOSTO HNOISRY U
H
NT PATOIF MEINGF
IORENGSSLNAVE OIGRSHT
,LCO
COIORENGSSSTL NAMAN'ATICIOO'S
THIVECEXUTRAE BHNC
.
WHENAM JIL HESAMNEN,TO OEF  OTH
ME TS EROFHEM, TEABAOE GS
CO
OO LKGHHR TOUHE T H FTOISRY
ANTHE OGS HA WRECOT NG
S
NGTRYIO T DO,HAT E COEITMMTE
WA TYITRNGHEDOO , SOI PNT TO
'RENGS'SNV ITITIESGAON
ET  ATH
BALEF  OUNLLBU R IN1186 11
0S
ISERTHE HAOT N TTEXAN MY
HIFOR ULTOM  PL FM.RO
ATTHTTOM CMILL REEEA
TABLFOHEISS FITHR E TRSIM TE
ESAGGRVE CGRES
ONSIAL
SIOVER TT GHOFCU EHEXEVETI
ANBRCHND A AOLS AOFENOMT
MU T-SSTEEMEINV  AHICARIN
.
STHATMEUMR O1973IF YOUAL
T
O
T LM AOS WYOANNE WHOASLI A
VT
HA TT THEE,IM T TWIY LLKAL
OUABTT  WHABIA GEA DLSE THO
WALLO--TWAVEV  TCOGERAF O
THINHEE ARNE TGSURTOOUD T E B
T TINHAT.OM MEN
THEGEVE ARACAME ARIEHHON USDOL
HEEROV TEOU CRS OSUTHF E ERMM O
CH W73ATESOS ALMOU40T  H
F
THEOM CTTMIEESI, BAA LLCAY LLFU
RKWOK  WEEMI COFOMEETTRI HEASNG
D AIREVE OABC, CBSD, AN
PUICEL TN ISEVIO
TINHE
GSENEVIN T ANDTHAESEC BOM -
A
SKETA S O ORSUTCOTHF E EITMMTE
COFUT O OEO PKEE PLLI
OH N
AN AND HCK BISLO
STBUER
TEYIMSTONAR ETH ILYN EEA H
S
D ANTOLPHES  TEG BINONG CHA
ONEPRCTITEF  OWA
ATRGE.E
INDET NDPEEN,N RYNELI.TH
CAERLL: YOUNO DO IOMET NT
T
OFTWO HE TGL BURSARE.ER WE
HOT  HRDUNURD ANSTS.GI
THEERN AS W AIVEROPATTHFOE R
E
CID  TOLAS ATOSS NNASITEONIX
TBUIDE  HSAULE  HWODONOD T T. I
A HHEADAMOD CEN
E.ONIX.
ARRDFO PNEDOD N
XONIGOWAN S  RG INTOWHEAEVL
AN
HA IENPPEDASDAN LLSEEC BAU
WASHE T.RE
HEAS W A AILOU CNCPEIT WH I.PS
S ATTH IINMESOTHSHYOG U LDOU
ECCHKN O
HO:STBEHI TS PAUSCAE  ORTF
E
TIQUESR  OONVER ETWHHEAE THCI
HAROLEN I WATGATE,
R
LEKNOWEDGF OTTANR  AOPTEM T
SAHEGETA TARUR BGLHA PY,ER
NGYIGE TO THT EUR B
ARGLSR
STARRE.ED
ISERTHE NCVI EDEELTOE  BVEIE
HEATTH T CIAAD HDEUC MH EREP
DGOWKNLEIXOFE  N'O'S
IR DTY
KSTRICN  THAETEYTH LN. O
AR HE.OWDUN HT, RME THFO
BULARGRS C TE ONOFER OHETHERC.
RSRGBULAAM CEUT OEF  OTHAN CUB
IMANGRTATOP PULNKN IOLIED T
OY
OFBAE Y IG PSND W ACT
HEON TIA CAY PLLROTH ON TNIE GH
OFURHE T BANARGLY RTRED PO
BACK THAHIO S  TLENDRS TOUHRGH
TIOLWHE WA HMEE INWOS RKG O
E
OSORTY DIF RTICTRKSEA T
TT
ORG. GNDO LNDDYID AWA.  EHO
RDU
LE PNTULTOGEER.
ARERTHE D WEE IRS MEMONT.REWE G
GOONID LDYHI IN  AROS LE
T
HEOF TMB PLURKS ERWO TG ININ
CIA RFO HP.ELOE USTORNTUS HE THE
E THOVA CIPRIMESID HIT WH
A
SGDISEUITH FURER BYGLURAR O
AL
RIHIYCATSTFF OEIC INHE T
OF971 TER NTE THPEONAG
APEPARSRESEEL REA
ETHEVIA C DOPELSIL FM.
HA TT
ONGORD LASDYID H TURENAK DGIN
HE ONOFISAK TUTEOSA OF
PSSTATHIRIFF OEIC A
GND.
ONGORD LURDYID CNTREHEHE WN
COUP WHRAIS H G
OPNATERIO --GO G. IDONRD L
DYWH
CO HENE SMEWI UP  G HTHISND
OPIOATNLA PFON R
THE
ECREELONTI TIR DTYCKS,HE
IOMILLARDON-LLRA OPEHAONTI T
T
INLVES
HIRG PRTETIOSTUTOS
DUSEOC DCEEMTIRACIC OFFSPLSIA,
Y
ANESLABU, RGIKESRI L WWHE AT
E
SEINE  WTEERATGADNTHT E
C
FIOFSCEHE --  TUR TNSTHO E
A
AVTO H MTHE EMEAKEP  UTH CRTHAS
HEOF THL HSEIGGAILY LES,PLL AN
SOALHA TT VESTMO ERYTHTE SP
ISCIA DEOR ME LYEPWA AWH OREF
TAKGIN PMICELA ADHE T
RE
ANINCRD IMOFITALY RDIC RHA NONIX
THENE WND UD STEROO T TATHEE.IM
HO:STTOEX NT THAM SANONA  THE
PEINDELIENNDT .NE
:LLCAER ALOLIA FE S RNGED
OX
FAT WN,HA G WASRGEOE
NBSTEI
GEERR?
--E EO GRGEREISTNBR'G'S
VOINT?EMLVEN
GUT:NE OEF  OTH T BIGTHNGHIS
E
PAUSCAE TH ORTF RGWAE TEEAT
DASCANLF O IHE TSECKERNTLOGIN
LSANSCDAHA TTNF UDOLISS  ITH
RU OFLL IAMALEG CIGPAN
CEIN FAN
OFIXHE T NONIGAM CPASE TN,HE
ILLGA DNSATONIO OMA, NY
M
INASH, EDNNFUELE O  TTH
XN
CAAIMPGNN  IRIE THSPNG OF97 12 I
OMDEMA SGICHE ANPA CNGAMNIG
ENAFINCAW LS
GEORTE SNEBRINENR A
HNDS
MPCOD Y ANENNG BUPEIAUGHP U
TIDONAS.ONMEOSF  OTHGAILE LE
ESTHRDREE COONAV HE E  CLYOMTOU
L TATHEUPT ASCOLERS YEAT  AETH
LEI FBFIWES REEL RSED.
FOAV HE FITHR E TRSE  TIM
AGO
ODER UNDNGANSTDIORF  OGE
EINB'NNREE'S R AE OLINS. TLLHI
TH CAS W AEASRE WHE TREHE
E
NSDOZEERF  OAMANICOR CONRAPOTI
N HTUG ILLISTH IINALEG F
G
MESCHEAMRO FM  AICERANS LIIRNE
O
YEODAR, IR TESFNYMA OHE T--M
MAPO CNYORXETERA ES TICUVE
G
INCRIMRG CALHA AESS AEL WL,
LLA
OFHE TOT T69 OALF EEO PPL
ALENEVTULYND IFOTEICD GECHR AR
T
FMIEMNGMROAT WGAERTEND ALL A
SOE THAS SATCIEDS.NDCAAL
:HOST WEIL WHEARRO F IBIM LL
L
, NOLIISICPUREBLE. LANIN
CA:ER IE  HAVTIQUA ES.ON
U E ARYOARMIFALIJEIT WH
'PAEPR'SEW N TOO BK,ON NHEIXSH
CO?RAPICY
T:GUES A I
ERCALL:AV I HRENOE T  B TADHEKOO
T.YE
ETHRUT AHOKE WORHEIND  T
IN
E WHIT
USHOE.
HELA CSIMUM DOCHATSEN TT HSHA
NDENSE AERNC UOVED IEICNDAT
WAXONIN SES TBY UP IE V AAR
F
PEITLEOP WNHIHE TNMOV GERT,
INTHINUDG ECPRE O'ORUT'S
.FIOFCE
GUT:ESHIS COME OPAS RT
W
THEER WATTEGATORYAS S
D
UNAND LDFOED OE R VETH0STLA 5
YE
HAERTHE S BNEE AF OT L O
CT
LASCHOINHIRSP ASHE T LR 20T  O
ARYENGTRS YI TOMA REINEGI
DCHRIAR AIX NONVITHS E FIMCT O
RGWATETHE ATRAN  TERHAETH
RARPPEETR.TO
ANTHD ISA  IDEATTHE HAT-  -TH
FIKES RELIHIIS H C OEFF SFFTA
EDHELP HOR FCEM FIMROE FF OIC
N
END END AHE TRERE ANSEA RSOO T
E LIBEEVOFRTPAS HA TTRY STO
,
SAS IDAI ELIARERCH, RIDAR
'XONIN'SAN PARDOIIN MNDETDS A
S
ASPERVEIVNARI CMISTYLI I CARLE
AN PSDARETE TGL BHEURDY ARAN
COUPR-EL ITSI SF,O HI TNK
THIS AAY T ALOO OKT
HS
ITHATSUEHE T QION  WHA
TT F
ESSPANIREF BE E ORTHGHNIT
NEJU 12 WH THEARUR BGL
E
EDREARSTHAND A WSPTRT ANESIR
TEAFR.
IITS TLE CAR LT HAATEFSTEA BEOR
19REBE- FOHA TT NNHTIG IE JUN
7219 WIX NON TASHETRER PPEORAT
TOFHE M ADSINETME CNDRI
AND
ABUS OFOW PT  TERHADLEO  TATTH
ANGHNIT E THD OSS.REARST
ST: HOW H IPFELUL
YON UR
ARRESECHAS WIXHE T NRA LONIB
RN
ORAL CIFA?NI
ESGUT: TON NHEIXRYIB LRA
AA
MPLITED RNSATELIOTHP HIWI
WA
ATRGE.
ITAS BN EEA LNNG ONRUGIN
TTBALEET BHEENWE TDERE PSI,NT
ENWH HALWAE S E.IV
TE WHEAND TO H GETES TISAP A
BUAFHE TM SR TEHI PNCSIREDEY
.
NATHE  AONTIALS HIRCVES FOHT
FOREC DO ESAD TY TRTO PESERERV
THOLWHERY STOF  OETHIX NON
PEIMT,HMACENGAAT WERE, TETH
NIIDPRN ES
CYEN.
IT H ONL RBEY ENELATELIV
LYCERENT TND UERHE LEARSHIPY
F
NITHE BRN XOLIYARTOIR DECRTHA
E HWEAVN SEE TEESEHO KFRSPE O
THEGXTNE LYACSE RUSH WLLIT
NI'N'LERU TE
CYGA.
NOWATHW E ERGTEATTO SRY I
TE
SIARLENG LXHSTGE ET ITIB AE
NERYIB LRATHBU, T EE ERAR
STTA L LOF O URTOMNCFOSSLEABNE
TABOU T HOWROCOO NF T ANTNDLEL
ORE THSTOFY AT WGAERTEMO A
NGNI
YAN XOLO
STLIS.
HO:ST AEOU CPLORE LLS.
FIEVIST  KTE IINN S.XA
ERLL:T  WHA TWAI NTHE GOSTUE T
EX HN AIISOW CPLOMEX PSITOLIC
IS
NIWAS POLI.CITIAN
NNIXOID D O L AOT TGOF OD
,
T A LO T BOFAD
NGHIS.
JULA ESTXP TINOHOPLEOE
WPO
TICIS ARANE DHE THEDOY  T
SA THI TNG
AYOD.
>>ISHI TS FNE O O T THE
NGHS
THES MATAKGAAT WERTEAS FNGNACITI
TO AHAS LFRYEN CTU,AT LER
RIXOD ARNIINFAN SCTOINATG  U
ISTHFIX M O L THENDHTIG A DK
,
IDTHE T  TEAHAY MINANS WAY
D
RGWATEEAT HEV NERD,PEAPNE
RIXOD ARNIN WLDOUE AMEG ONTH
MOQUON CSE PTIENALNTSIREDEOFS
THE TH20RYEN CTU
HEHEAS W T PIR FSTNTSIREDEO T
A SIVIT MMUNT C CNTOURY
G
ISTO VITCO MOSNGCOW MISIO  TVI
T
INCH
--NIOM CMUNT CSTOU,RY T
ST
OWMOSCTO VIT C
NAHI.
ND WHEOUOW DNTN VHEIE. WAMAR
HE TATREEDIR EHENVALMEONNT
PR ATIECONNCY.
NE SHEIGE TID TLIXLAEG LIS
.
INAN MYAY WRE HS,E LYALEDHA CNG
THFACEE F  OTHY.UNCOTR
ALYET OFL HAT I
NOS W
THSHORWIDEAND S  TTHHILANSCDA
THOMAS H CTOE  DINE LAL
SCHEOTR  ADAANLSRGWAS TEE.AT
STHO: IN72RG GASEOVEMCE GO?RN
HE WELS INRETIECON72 IN Y TH
TRGLAESLIAN LDSAM IDEN
ICN
IDPRES HTIENAL.TOISRY
D,ANISHA TT OFAR PT EEHE T D
P
ONIRYRAND A TFDYGE OATER
,
OFALL  DHE TSETYIRCK TRISHAT
HED NCAUHE TTORYO TPE SHAHE T
72LE EWEIOCTN REBA PROTY BLNO
NEAL AEDT HEANL D  HOU CLDEAV
D ASCOTETOCTEE RLEN,IO ENVE
T THWIOU TY ANOFT.HA
LESTHO: TARS  UHEJORO FM ONE
E INPENDNET ENLI
ERLL:D GOOOR MTHNGNI, UK ANYO
SOR H UCFOOUATWH YO. D
.MRRA G,FFAY M I A ASK
ER VY
PE QONRSALN?STUEIO
ATR  YEAOUREWE Y
OR BN?
T:GUES
98 11.
WWHATR  YASOUE RPPUOSTI WINRI
H
K  BISOOHEOTRHAN, A IM
NO
OWKN ILWIST  AODS AYGOKEO  TMA
SOEY MMEON CUT B IFINOANT REGU
TOU YHE WRE C AOUREFRINOMG .OM
I LEE S APA OOTF S LLRAELNTWBEEE
THERU TIN AMPDMIOTRISATTHANN D
I
NXOIN ADMIOTRISAT I AN,ND
WO LJUD STE IKTO KWNO
HEE
YOARE NGCOU MI FD M ROANSATWH I
THE RPPUOS TOFHE
OO BK?
IWILLHET LP UST  AIMISTH T
EN OOC DUREMS CYRA I
INBEG
ATTHRE
EDEN?
E WHER TU YOATT?HA
--STHO,  HETT:OS LARS  UHE
M
GUOUR T.ES
ESGU TS ISN IMT RTPOANRTPA
TOFHE TTO SRYT HAI AAS
LIURJONAST HAVSPENLATHT E
SI TVEO SYEX AROV C
INERGI
'SSRUI'SK TT AAC TONHE 2
EL ATIECON M TNDHE
LEULR
STINVEN ATIGIOERD ANEV
HIYG
THATNF UBEDEOLD OFUSCAE
H.
ATWHE W HENE AVSEISS  ITH
RAPAINSILYS UR OIT POLHES,IC T
POONZARITI AND PN TIARSA
E
UROF OICOL PIT
WATWH ITEANDDO TO O AS W TKETA
UEISTH QIOSTNF  OENESPRIDALTI
USESF PNDEROW ACKO  GBA
A
MOHENTME WINWAN SHORONGT WD.KE
BEUSCAE WGATEAS INAY S I
THS OKBO IY MINAN WES AYTH
EAGRST SRY ELDR VETOWF  OHO
POR U IOLNFDSINWAN SH
ONG.
AND,T IA  IS  WMEMONTOUREHE Y
SELL AE F  OTHUTSTINITFNSIO O
AMANICER GOV TENNMT,HE P
,
STE THJUPAE ICDE,MERTNTHE T
EXIVUTENC BRACI SH,PE
UTOSPRECOUS,OR CNDS,RT AAT SEN
O
ME TR ETOGHETO TOR FCESHI
ALIMCRIN ARU CNDORSI PPTRENTDE
FFOMFR OE.IC
SOINWA, SHONGTOR WDKEM FRO
97TO 1
U YOLE SEALE F  OTHHAYSWA TTHE
CH B AKSNDSANALCEOU OF
TITINSTUES CONOMHEOG TETR, TO
ATY WATH A OICRTLEKS WNEOR
H
CLARTITWE O, AEE TNDHRO T
HIACISE EVTHRAR LGEL GOA O
PR OTIECNGOC DUREMNDCYRA A
PR OTIECNGER GUROV
ENNMT.
FORE, M TLIELNGORS HISTYTOY DA
IS LBO AUT BKIOONG AK ACAT
MONTSHN  IWA'GTINO'S H
TY
OWHENER GUROVENNMTOR WDD KEAN
SU
DEEED.
ANSOD , W ITEAND THALLTE T
IDPRES ATIENALOFSEBUS  PSEROW AT
A Y WATOEF RCT T EVEATS NTTH
WEEAV LHREDIV TVEGHOU O
TE
FLASTARE IVYE
AS IAID TO S, EOOMNE
NADD
UMTR'P'AM N AONE LYEAPPRS
NE
ET,BU HMS LOO P HNDISSIREDEYNC
ALOMLOS STMO A--OSLMT TLM AOS
OV PVE ERYE.AG
P.REISHA WT HE TUT CHO -- :ST
S ATWH INTE THCOT?EX
ESGUT:T  THA M HHEASEDTIENONN I
NTE THCOTEXF O CTHNGHAE
ATRI
ARCHDIX NNG BONRIO  TETH
ICPUREBLTY PANAR
RTHATHARDIXON''TH SOUNER
GYRASTTE BETEGSHIS RNTU
WATOSRD RZEIAACLIDNAAT NIO
,
MMTIAN-IRAIGNT PSITOLIC
HA T
FALRELYTSDSIN IALAT NUR
COSILUONN  IIT1620 WH
THE
NANOMINDONTI AIOLE ECTOFN
TNADOLD
MPRU.
:HOSTLLAN RDA ISILON UIA.AN
ERCALL:.EL HLO
AHAI VEEFEW F RNSCTLEIO ON
T
AUTHE S ORTH I.YISANG
I  CS WAINLEGEHEN ISTH
EDPPHAEN
D,AN REMBER
G EE SINETH
SELETEVIDNGEA HRISI , THINTHK
T
TH SHO DD ULBENGOI TTHA
STYEDAERYIT WFOTHH E ERRM
ENESPRID
T BUD WOI ULYSAHA TTFOT L O
ETHLY ACODS TEANDEFF OEN
OF
HAUMTRP N  BVEEER  OONVEETH
ARYES, ULRTPAICILLYAR WAMLI
ANDORMI WHT O  ILLCAEDNHE WNOU Y
M D HAHIPA CON-S YMAN NYRSEA
O.AG
AN HD,E T WASKINGBOUTOW H
DCHRIARIX NUL SONHO NHAD VEEREV
ENBESE PRO ATECUD,ND A H IAD
SIST QLEUERN IOFOTHIM H,
F LEOP OITE THUNED SKNTETAS EPE
B
CHT OURIDARIX NON IN 12,97
HEATWH TYOU F A ONDUTIMUTBO H
N
7319 TWH, ATVEY HEHA FOT VED
OI
:STIE B IELTH IVET E.ER
Y ANTSMMCOENNAR  OFIGHTHL OU?TS
ESGUT: T AS HIISARIG B PT
OF
LOOKG BACKT  ATOISTH SRY
IS
T ATWH IN TEH USISN  ITH
MO.NT
THD ANI KINHE TRBAN
TTOM CMI
E
LYAL A HASFOT L ONSES LSOOR F
NUE THJAY AR6 CEEMIOMTTS  A
ITN
LDFOS AKS WNDORY O  TTRDAN
TOINBRG IG LHTRUHE T TWH OTHF
R
EDSPANIRNUN  OJA
Y AR6.
DANONHE T C ESTTEEDNCTLEIO
IN
.2020
TH TISO AE  MISTHOO BK AT
SS
LTHISS ENOF HTOISRYO  TLLTE
S
T A LOOUTT  WHADER OUMO
RNTI
PS MEINSITOLIC CAN BANE
D
OULDE, BHAND A WHOWET  SDUL
E
LOOKG TOUR OEA LO RSDE T
BEDO
TG INATEN MHEOM
T.HO
:ST TT  IIS NEWOOK
ON
TEWA "ATRGE,RGWATE NE:AT A
EW
Y.STHIOR
EAT  HU E AVYOS.THWI U
ESGUT:HA T F YNKOUIN HORAV
.
HO:STHA T DWIT LLORITO  F
HS
INMORN'G'GR PRO.AM
WEACRE A BRRTOK MONI MOWOR
T
7:00.M. N.STEAER
E  HWEOPE U YOARO.TO
ENE Y JOTHF STRE OAYURYO D
.♪
AP[CCOONTIS T RIPYGHALTINAON
CALLSAE TERPE ITCO]20. 22
[CG ONTIINMERFPEORHEBYD  T
H WHICPO RISES FIBNSLE  IORTS
CANTN IOCOD T ENANCYCUACRA
.VI
ICT SINC].OAPRG
♪